you did bring something you want to talk
about which is you have a line of wigs I
do I have a line of wigs which you can
get them on Lux hair calm I'm on QVC all
the time and these are very nice I don't
know much about wigs but you yeah the
wigs are good for for people they wait
you know I love wigs it's like you were
born with the hair you got now get the
hair you want and these are the Sherri
Shepherd
these are Sherri Shepherd now wigs and
this is great because you can either
have your wife wear wig she can be a
different woman every night or you can
wear the wig conan you can put the wedge
on should I do that when you put it on
just like that put it on Oh
yeah give that to Andy kind of like the
silver five I think it's it probably is
gonna be more like Golden Girls I think
there's some women getting a little
tingly in their nether regions I'm not
this kind of says ladies billiards
champion yeah it's a lot of freaks in
the billiards room there's this one
right here this is I don't this is a
very unusual one what's this all about
I don't so funny this could go either
way this is very like is he a guy is he
a girl who really cares
it is Saturday night we've got some time
I like that you tuck it behind the ears
my little textured pixie and ombre color
kind of tuck it behind your ears
put a little diamond hoop in there okay
well these are beautiful these are
really nice yeah you go to Luke's hair
calm and get any wig you want it's
really I like it okay luxe herecan let
me ask you about trial and error yeah
your character very interesting I'm just
keeping this on I don't care
yeah keep it on I mean I'm keeping a
sign for the year you know it's your
birthday do something new yeah you never
dump your character on trial and error
it's people love this character because
your character suffers from a series of
disorders yeah but it's very unusual and
they're realistic they're real disorders
but they're unusual yeah I'm part of a
the legal defense team defending John
Lithgow and I have facial amnesia so I
can't recognize faces I was born with no
tear ducts I'm Dyslexic I laugh
inappropriately when they talk about
murder I think when I see beautiful
artworks I walk backwards when I get my
flu shot when I get anesthesia I talk
like Adele with a British accent as
alien hand syndrome it is saying that's
just among the many disciplines these
are things that are all real all real
disorders your character has all of them
and your character also faints
constantly yeah it's called sindelle
syndrome so if I see beautiful artwork I
just fake dead away and and the problem
is is I'm representing I'm trying to
defend John Lithgow but I can't
recognize his face I prosopagnosia so I
can't recognize who I'm defending right
so it makes for you know some really
crazy stuff on trial and error well the
show is fascinating you can watch all
episodes of trial and error on nbc.com
where's my oh there we go hi
and you can see Sherry's theatrical
production all I needed was a key on
Studio City at the two Rhodes Theatre
everyone's in Rhodes theater Studio City
California for tickets to go to all I
needed was a hug yeah this is my new
look and I mean for all of time do you
brother do you have an uncle do you not
you know cuz I said I'm trying to if I'm
gonna go down the vanilla slope I just
you know
you have somebody in your family that
looks like you yeah yes thank you I had
an unmarried brother named Neil that's
who I would like to me I think you want
to be with me I think I want to be with
no Kenny buy me a car kid I mean like
I'm gonna get you a car they have a job
done get you a car okay I'm good just in
my own car I just want somebody who can
do it as well there's nothing I can't do
okay all right I gotta clean up you and
Sheree it's Jerry Shepard Neil O'Brien
my purse backstage a prenup and a
confidentiality agreement you got
assigned a boat it's a done deal
you